hey 42 here most deaths are pretty
self-explanatory but ever so
occasionally a case comes along that
baffles even the savviest of detectives
these are the deaths that have no
explanation and no motive we could just
put these cases to bed and be done with
it but where's the fun in nut
there's something about a good murder
mystery case that makes people obsessed
with finding out the truth these are the
five most unexplainable deaths the world
has ever known
first up is the mysterious disappearance
of Morgan Donna Harrington she was a 20
year old student at Virginia Tech
University in Blacksburg Virginia on the
17th of October 2009
Morgan attended a Metallica concert in
Virginia with a few friends whilst a
support act was still performing Morgan
went off on her own to use the bathroom
since she didn't want to have to go
after Metallica had come on stage after
an unusually long time Morgan had still
not returned from the bathroom
Metallica then came on stage and Morgan
was still nowhere to be seen her friends
grew very worried they rang Morgan and
she picked up she told them she had not
been allowed back into the venue because
of a no reentry policy but this was very
strange because there were toilets
inside the venue yet Morgan had
mysteriously gone outside for no good
reason at all Morgan told her friends
not to worry and enjoy the concert
without her she told them she would make
her own way home having trust in Morgan
her friends stay to enjoyed the rest of
the concert
unbeknown to the fact that their friend
was in grave danger witnesses later said
that they saw Morgan outside the arena
on her own she was never spotted with
anyone but her friends throughout the
entire night which leaves no explanation
as to why she exited the venue someone
or something must have made her act so
strangely but what was it she was
spotted by a witness hiking along the
side of the road later that night still
on her own
she was not seen again for several weeks
until a farmer several miles from the
venue of the Metallica concert found the
skeletal remains of a young woman on the
outskirts of his property the remains
were confirmed to be that of Morgan
there were signs that her death had been
extremely violent and she had been raped
there was extremely little evidence to
go on and what had led Morgan out of the
arena that night and caused her to end
up dead at a farm several miles away is
still a mystery to this day
in 2013 at the Cecil Hotel in the
notorious Skid Row neighborhood of Los
Angeles one of the creepiest and most
unexplainable deaths of the 21st century
took place in the days leading up to
February the 19th 2013 hotel guests had
been complaining of low water pressure
and oddly colored foul smelling and
tasting water some even said the water
coming up the tucked was black in color
when the hotel staff went up to the roof
to investigate the cause they were
shocked to find a body in the water type
through a hole 19 days hundreds of
guests at the hotel were bathing in
brushing their teeth with and even
drinking the water from a tank on the
rooftop that contained the decomposing
corpse of a college student the body
turned out to be that of 21-year old
Canadian student ELISA Lum LUMS death is
shrouded in mystery 19 days before being
found dead in the water tank Lam had
gone missing while staying at the hotel
on the day of her disappearance dis
disturbing CCTV footage was released
from inside the hotel elevator the video
went viral on the internet love appears
to be hiding from someone she starts
behaving erratically and at one point
waved her arms around in an odd fashion
before finally disappearing she was not
seen again until 19 days later when her
body was found inside the water tank on
the roof
but apart from the fire escape the roof
is only accessible via a set of stairs
and locked doors which only hotel
employees have the keys and passcodes to
the doors would set off an alarm if
anyone else tried to open them
yet Elise alarm and managed to somehow
get through the doors and onto the roof
without setting the alarm ah not only
that what she managed to get inside one
of the water tanks which is 2.4 meters
tall and has no fixed access the hotel
staff had to put a ladder up to check
inside it so how on earth did Elise alum
get in there even more bizarrely lamb
also managed to somehow close the
extremely heavy lid on herself once
inside the town which will be extremely
difficult if not impossible to do by
herself in fact the water tank was so
tightly sealed that authorities had to
drill a hole into it to get her body out
this has led many people to believe that
her death was suspicious which probably
goes about saying considering it would
be nearly impossible for lamb to end up
in that water tank all by herself but
with insufficient evidence her death was
marked as accidental and to this day
nobody truly knows what happened to
Elise alum a locked-room mystery is a
unique sub-genre of murder mystery
fiction in which a murder takes place in
a seemingly locked room with only one
person inside the victim in these
stories the murder seems to take place
under impossible circumstances it's
extremely rare that these so-called
locked room mysteries actually happen in
real life but one such case did happen
in 1937 in Paris - lady Totoro at 6:27
p.m. lady Totoro boarded a metro train
at the Port de Charenton when she got
onto the train she was the only person
in the first-class carriage however when
the train pulled into the next station
only 1 minute and 20 seconds later at
6:28 p.m. lady Turturro sloped forwards
in her seat with a dagger in her neck
she had somehow been stabbed in the neck
and killed in seemingly impossible
circumstances witnesses at both stations
swore that they saw no one getting on
- or leaving - Rose train compartment at
either stop and witnesses in both
adjacent compartments said that nobody
had tried to enter the one where - Rose
body was found police tried their best
who solved a mystery but even Paris's
best detectives had no idea how to row
could have been stabbed in the neck in a
time span at one minute in a seemingly
empty train carriage World War two came
and - Rose case was forgotten about
despite crime writers the world over
giving it their best
nobody has since been able to solve this
infamous real-life locked room mystery
Italian man art Aveo batasia was one of
the most talented cyclists the world has
ever seen
in 1924 he became the first Italian to
win the world renowned Tour de France
race he was also the first person in
history to maintain the lead in the Tour
de France all the way from start to
finish but the fame and glory was
short-lived for bata Xie because in June
1927 two years after his second Tour de
France victory but teshia was found dead
at the side of the road in the village
of penas Italy just a few miles from his
home so what's so strange about this it
just sounds like a bicycle crash well
bata Shia's bike was a few metres from
his body completely undamaged with not a
single mark or scratch upon it no skid
marks were found on the road and there
were no signs that he had been forced
from the road or that he was in a
collision at all yet but a Shia's body
lay in the road with his skull smashed
in a snapped collarbone and numerous
other broken bones if that wasn't
suspicious enough the authorities came
to the conclusion that he had died of a
sunstroke skull smashed in 20 broken
bones looks like a bad case of sunstroke
chief this ridiculous cause of death led
many conspiracy theorists to come to the
conclusion that patel was killed in a
government assassination for speaking
out against authoritarian prime minister
Benito Mussolini and his murder was
by the police to this day we still have
no further clue as to what happened to
legendary Italian cyclist Ottavio bata
Xie who put Bella in The Witcher that
was the question on everyone's lips in
1943 it all started on the 18th of April
1943 when four boys were poaching in the
hugly woods near which Berryhill in
Stourbridge England the boys stumbled
across a large witch elm tree believing
it would be a good place to find bird's
nests one of the boys climbed up the
tree to his horror the boy looked down
inside the trees hollowed out trunk and
he saw a human skull with heaven teeth
one of the boys reported it to the
police and when they investigated they
found almost an entire skeleton inside
the trunk of the witch shell
they also found a shoe a gold wedding
ring some fragments of clothing and the
severed hand which was buried in the
ground near the tree after forensic
examination it was determined that the
body was a female and she had been dead
for at least 18 months
taffeta was also found in her mouth
suggesting that she died from
asphyxiation but then things got weirder
a year after the body was discovered
strange graffiti started to appear in
random locations in the surrounding area
first on a wall in Opa dean street
birmingham and then in several more
places over the next few decades until
the last graffiti was sprayed onto the
side of a 200 year old obelisk known as
which burry obelisk in August 1999 the
obelisk is located on which Berryhill
haggling near where the body was found
every single one of the graffiti said
the exact same thing
who put Bella in the which shell the
identity of the killer and out of the
graffiti artists were never discovered
thanks for the view subscribe for more
you